- I have been working on
the US history content here
for more than two years now.
And we have a team of experts who've been
in the classroom for many years,
who have advanced degrees in US history,
who really rigorously write, tape,
and edit each other's work.
And I think it would be kind of,
I would judge it as like
a day's worth of class.
Everything that we've done
on the Khan Academy website
meets the AP requirements.
So teachers can feel confident
that when they send their students
to watch a video or read an article
or practice with an
exercise on Khan Academy,
that students are taking away
the key learning objectives
that they should get for the AP exam.
- [Instructor] It's a frequent
misconception that people
in this time period thought
that the world was flat.
- We really wanted to make this material
approachable and fun.
And so throughout, I
think, students will see
a real enthusiasm for the
material and a sense of humor,
so that it's not just
reading a history textbook.
- [Instructor] So I've brought you here
to talk about the Gilded Age,
which is one of my favorite
eras of American history.
- [Man] Because everything
was great and covered in gold?
- It's really interacting with some
of the big questions of history,
and having an opportunity to
explore those with enthusiasm.
- [Instructor] No,
because it is the only era
of American history I can think of
that has a sarcastic name.
(man laughs)
- Because it is fun.
We hope to give students that sense
that history is not a boring subject.
It's really fun.